hello and welcome to a Playstation
grenade I finally gave for tonight's
battle royale mode the time it deserves
and I have to admit I'm completely
addicted now I started off absolutely
terribly getting killed almost right
away but after a few battles I pieced
together a few tips and tricks which
made me a better player in solos and
with teammates I won't be talking about
landing on roofs and finding chests are
the best weapons to use either I think
at this point you all already have a
handle on that instead this is 8 ways to
turn a good player into a great player
ok let's do this I'm starting with the
single action which got me my first solo
win in Battle Royale using the bushes as
a hiding spot it sounds ridiculous I
know but you'd be surprised how
successful it can be most opponents will
be searching for buildings to loot or
player made constructions and will most
likely miss a man in a bush especially
in duels and squads my favorite course
of action is to ambush an unsuspecting
player and quickly retreat back into the
bush using the weapons and resources
they drop as bait for yet another kill
I'm sure in due course these spots will
be checked more often but at the moment
it currently works perfectly heck I've
even been taken down by a bush dweller
myself and man it hurts you're right
during the endgame if you are looking
enough to find a bush near two enemies
completely focused on one another then
pick your moment to attack the survivor
hey sometimes they'll even do the job
for you right time to go on the
offensive hey everyone we follow mr.
bolo
other times grenades and rockets can
freak out a fall causing them to
frantically search for you and then your
shotgun is your best friend the next tip
is one I personally hate with a passion
but there is no denying it can be highly
successful jumping around like a madman
especially in close range exchanges the
theory is simple a moving target is hard
to hit but it's the added element which
makes this a reliable technique
as headshots are the fabled crit area
jumping and shooting down on an opponent
with a shotgun stacks the odds of a
headshot in your favor
I'm absolutely terrible at it and prefer
boots on the ground but anyone who plays
the recent Call of Duty titles titanfall
Orem lawbreakers will be able to use
this strategy with ease here's an
example when this chap is jumping around
my aim is all over the place but as soon
as he's back on the ground I can
absolutely melt him a minor tip I
believe is worth mentioning happened
right at the start of the game when
jumping out from the party bus your
glider or umbrella will pop at a certain
distance from the ground but it will
activate earlier if it's above mountains
buildings or trees if you want to get to
the ground quicker drop above ravines
low level areas or skirt the island
shoreline is an example when going for a
loop lake I tend to jump later than
everyone else and aim for the stream or
in between the hills then when my
umbrella pops I slice through the air
and reach the target first then
hopefully I've got to drop on other
players pistol there's also something to
be said about landing last whilst other
players are flying out of the bus like
misguided sperm I jumped out as late as
possible and glided all the way to the
ground and look almost half the
population were already dead and even
better than that I actually won that
game so first down on the ground isn't
always the best tactic next it's the
question to bait or kill when an enemy
is riddled full of bullets they fall to
the ground waiting for help from a
teammate in duels I highly recommend
using the downed enemy as bait to draw
out their partner in crime potentially
losing half your team causes that
last-man-standing to push forward to
save their fallen comrade and depending
on how they approach it two against one
they haven't got
it's easy enough in squads I recommend
the opposite surprisingly using a force
bait can be highly advantageous don't
get me wrong but the risk/reward doesn't
quite stack up in my opinion once our
squad started killing those stragglers
outright the opposition began running in
like mad dogs I actually understand this
mentality too if you are playing as a
group of four friends and lose a man or
two early on your odds of winning are
cut dramatically and your death friends
are stuck watching instead of playing
many teams will go on a kamikaze mission
me included two off one of the
Opposition squad as soon as possible
so do you bait or do you motorized I'd
love to know what your preference is
let's talk about reviving far too often
the building mechanic is completely
ignored in Battle Royale
most probably by those of us who started
out in player and notes battlegrounds
when a teammate hits the deck build a
shelter around them to both protect and
obscure the opposition's line-of-sight
if they decide to rush you you can be
set with a shotgun if they keep their
distance get your buddy back in the game
and just don't do what I did and
accidentally shoot your pal in the head
if you're watching hands
I'm so sorry fella it won't happen again
another underutilized building
opportunity is when you are looting a
corpse instinct usually takes over here
and we dart in grab gear and hopefully
get away quickly well a huge amount of
kills happen when people are looting
once again build around those goodies
and keep yourself and your team safe if
you remember my tactic from earlier I
actively use dropped weapons and other
Desirables to entice the opposition to
come over and then I ambush those new
book as soon dude another one bites the
dust have you ever tried to pick up
resources and accidentally pick up
weapons instead
well this mechanic will soon be changed
allowing us to walk through the drops to
instantly pick up materials and
consumables in the meantime though if
your inventory is full equip your
pickaxe and spam square to grab bullets
and other goodies without displacing
anything in your inventory this is
perfect for when you don't have the time
to think about what you're grabbing
friendly fire can be damn annoying but
you can use it to your advantage this
one may be patched in future but at
present if your teammate is below
percent health straight-up murder your
friend well down them don't eradicate
them completely
once you revive them they'll be back up
to 30% health this is a great way to
save bandages for the endgame battles
there we have it eight ultra quick ways
to be a little better at for tonight
Battle Royale I've decided to add for
tonight as a regular to this channel so
please sub for more but away our tips
and tricks I'm Adam from Playstation
grenades and I'm so addicted I'm going
straight back to battle royale now it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
well if I get a grenade to bounce off
the top of the stairs I could actually
um I did it that's my first ever team
kill I love this game